I'm Amelia McNamara.
I teach at the University of
Saint Thomas in Minnesota and I
tweet at AmeliaMN.
I just tweeted a link
to these slides in case
you want to follow along.
So I'm really
interested in R syntax
and also teaching statistics.
If you are someone who
teaches statistics,
that we are always
trying to have students
working with multivariate data.
So in this example,
looking at the relationship
between Flipper length and
Bill length of penguins
between different species to
see if that relationship is
the same.
And I chose this sort
of contrived example
to show you why educators
believe that we should not
be teaching base R syntax.
And that is because it can
get really complicated, really
verbose.
It's easy to make mistakes.
And if you look
at those graphics,
they don't even have the
same consistent axes.
So most educators
agree we should either
use the formula syntax like
from the mosaic package
or the tidyverse syntax.
And both of those are going
to create beautiful plot two
graphics with those
consistent axes,
but we have lots of opinions
about which of these
we should use and
not a lot of data.
So I did a semester
long, head to head
comparison of the formula
and tidyverse syntax.
Why did I do this to myself?
I basically doubled
my work, right?
I had to create the
materials in both syntax.
I tried to make them as
consistent as possible in R
Markdown documents
that had the same text.
The only thing that was
different was the R syntax.
And the reason for
this is because I
wanted to get us some data.
And I also really believe that
constraints breed creativity.
If you put those
constraints on yourself,
it's going to make
you more creative.
So here are my results.
Some things are
really easy regardless
of syntax. R Markdown
or quarto works so well.
Inference works
well in intro stuff,
whether using the mosaic
package for inference
or the infer package
and the tidyverse.
But different
things can be hard.
So in the formula
syntax, dealing with
and explaining how we
deal with missing data,
that's pretty challenging.
There's options.
There's no equal through
there use equal complete obvs.
That was tough in the tidyverse.
Dealing with and explaining
the relationship between two
categorical variables
was a challenge.
So we're used to seeing two
categorical variables explained
in a two way table.
That's not a tidy
data structure,
and it's harder for
me and for students
to conceptualize
of the relationship
when it's in that tidy format.
And that can have
implications when
you do things like chi-square
tests and proportion tests.
The other thing that I
was really interested in
is how much code you really
need in an intro stat course.
And it turns out not that much.
So in the formula section
I exposed students
to 37 functions.
In the tidyverse section
they saw 50 functions.
Those are a little bit
different in terms of numbers,
but both of them over
the course of 15 weeks,
totally reasonable.
A big criticism of the
tidyverse in teaching
is, oh, there's so many
tidyverse functions.
How would students
ever learn them all?
Well, they're not
going to learn them.
You're just going to show
them the 50 that they need.
And if you look at the top
five in each of these sections,
I think you'll kind of see
some of the differences
here as well.
So in the tidyverse section,
I use the summarize function
a lot.
Every time we did
summary statistics,
I use the plot function a lot.
Every time I built a graphic
versus in the formula section
in the top five, I have the
histogram that's apparently
the graphic that I made the most
and I have the mean function.
So a specific summary
statistic and you'd
see some of those
things kind of coming up
in the tidyverse section if
I went further down the list.
The other thing I
found is there was
a difference in the
amount of time students
were spending computing
on rstudio cloud, students
in the tidyverse section, it
looks like they spent more time
computing.
Why is this?
I have no idea.
I probably should have
collected some data,
done some interviews.
Asked them, is it
because you're on there?
You're like, oh, it's so fun.
I want to keep looking.
I want to play around.
Or is it because
it's really tough
and you're banging your
head against the wall
and you're frustrated?
I don't know.
And that's a great avenue
for future investigations.
If you want to try something
like this yourself,
if you want to know
how many R functions,
do I show my students, use the
R function, get parse data.
And if you want to know how much
time each individual student is
spending on rstudio
cloud, you can
dig into your browser's
developer tools
to sneak that data out.
If you want to know more about how I
did this and what I found out,
I've got a preprint
on the arXiv
and if you want my
materials like my
R Markdownn documents,
you want to see how I got
that data for all my functions
and how I analyze the
data from my paper?
You want to read the paper?
All of that is available.
I'm happy to take
questions on Discord.
And Thanks so much.